ااا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه
الخاصه والتي تمتده بها العربيه
التغطيه المستمره حرك كبير تشهده العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضيه
التي نكملها من قناه العربيه من المركز
الاعلامي في الرياض
اليوم في ظل تحديات حديثه تواجه المنطقه
والعالم
عصر جديد من الشراكه دشنه السعوديه مع
الصين في قمه عقدت اليوم في الرياض ورسمت
ملامح علاقات استراتيجيه تحمل الكثيره
للبلدين
مستحمل كلام ولي العهد السعوديه الامير
محمد بن سلمان بانه هذه الزياره وهذه
الرؤيه السعوديه بمستقبل الشركات العالميه
الاقتصاديه ليست وليده هذه الزياره اذا
اليوم
الى الحديث اكثر حول هذا الموضوع معي هنا
في الاستديو العربيه السيد عمر باحليوه
رئيس ديوان الاعمال الاساسيه للاستشارات
مباشره
في الاحمري مساء الخير نايف تفضل مساء
الخير خالد شكرا لك اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من
جديد
قادمون الان ليحلوا محله
الامريكيه
بالضروره
رؤساء الذين سيشاركون في القمه العربيه
الصينيه الجديده
ورؤيه 20 30 ومبادره الحزام والطريق همم
لتعاون اكبر بين السعوديه والصين
[موسيقى]